let's talk about the canadian trucker
story which really is
it's the story it's the story and i'm
going to keep hitting this thing and
hitting it hard
until mainstream media picks it up more
and honestly assesses it although i will
not hold my breath on that one uh first
we've got some video of the truckers and
this is just going through ottawa it's
absolutely fantastic connor let's throw
to that and i'm just going to talk
through some of this stuff
look at this i mean this is
hundreds and hundreds of trucks
thousands and thousands of people
they're saying now it could be 50 to 100
000 trucks that have made their way in
this convoy to ottawa this is incredible
these are good decent people
somebody was telling me it's something
like negative 20 out there these people
would much rather be inside it's nice
and warm inside i mean look at this it's
just absolutely extraordinary why are
you not seeing those images on cnn why
are they not leading with this story
right they'll start leading with it when
they can further twist the narrative
into that this is a white supremacist
rally right which they're really trying
to do we'll get to that in a sec but
when you just see the amount of people
out there and what are they there for
it's not because canadians suddenly
became racist it's not because canadians
suddenly decided to hate trans people
it's because canadians decided finally
to say you've pushed us far enough even
us
good-natured canadians we've had enough
eh
all right so we've got some more video
this is of the uh the convoy i think
we've got some more of that let's take a
look so this is the border of u.s
and canada i mean it's just absolutely
incredible look at that look at the
amount of people and they're at the
border and they're saying we're here and
we're an integral part of the economy
we're an important piece of getting you
guys goods and services and you've
pushed us far enough and we have to show
you that we have influence and a voice
one way or another but if you want to
see how mainstream media is covering
this
here's your warning everyone loves the
disclaimers and warnings i'm gonna have
to show you these clowns over at msnbc
this is joe and mika and god if you've
ever seen more smug people i'd like to
know who they are i'm just curious again
where were these protests when people
were required to take get five vaccines
to start school where were these
protests when people were required to
give their children five vaccines they
were in the doctor's office getting
vaccines they were in the doctor's
office getting vaccinated they were
making fun of left wingers on the west
coast for being loopy
anti-vaxxers okay now they have met the
enemy and the enemy
their enemy
is themselves because they've become
what they hated they've become what they
mocked and now they're taking food from
soup kitchens because they're so put
upon for being asked to do what they've
been asked to do required to do their
entire lives coming up
a
cult
yeah
you're
a
dick
like what
i almost said it i almost said the f
word trying to control the f-bombs
joe is obviously a multi-millionaire
that's his wife mika she's obviously a
multi-millionaire they are mocking and
she sits there like this
she sits there like this because she's
so outraged by these truckers and these
good decent people who are trying to get
control over their lives again and
risking everything that they've got she
sits there and they're in a cult they're
in a cult i honestly don't even
understand the point that he was trying
to make there is his point that they
should have been protesting earlier
because if that's his point then
probably yeah if all of us had been more
outspoken two years ago then maybe a lot
of this nonsense would have happened so
i don't know exactly what he's trying to
say there but the beginning
the anti-vaxxers these people are
anti-vaxxers
who are taking food from the homeless
the implication being that there's food
on the trucks or that food can't get to
homeless shelters or something to that
effect first off we have no evidence
that these people are anti-vaxxers in
the way that people would talk about
antibacterials are they anti-mandate it
sure seems like it is it possible that
75 of those people are are vaccinated
it's probable right like it's probable
it's possible i don't know all the
numbers on that nor does that idiot um
but these people they are just the worst
like they are the worst sort of elites
and i will never stand with them and i
will stand with those good people who
are out there it is just disgusting and
if you want to
see an elite guy if you want to know
what an elitist sounds like someone who
wants to rule over people who thinks
that he has dominion over the people who
have voted him into office for some
god-forsaken reason here's a tweet from
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
from yesterday
i'll try to do it in justin trudeau
voice i know this pandemic is
frustrating it's frustrating that after
two years we're not done fighting covet
19 but over the past few days canadians
have been shocked and frankly disgusted
by the behavior displayed by some of the
people protesting in our nation's
capital okay so what trudeau is trying
to do there is frame this as you know
these are terrorists they're white
supremacists the behavior the behavior
of some of these people now it's
interesting i've been watching an awful
lot of videos of these people and
they're in trucks they're waving flags
and there are words scary words like
liberty and freedom on the flags and
there's kids clapping for them and all
that stuff and i thought my god we've
got a staff of people here can we find
video of the bad behavior well we found
this
my god cleaning up trash at the end of a
protest is there anything more
disgusting more deplorable oh sorry man
sorry
ah is there anything more awful than a
group of free citizens coming together
you may have heard one guy say sorry to
the other guy as he was shoveling to
shovel the public streets could these
people be more awful and most likely
nazi adjacent my god that's what the
nazis wanted to shovel streets with
other people after protests
there are other people in canada who are
putting the pieces together so right
before we started the show i just saw
this video we had to throw it in
this is a woman by the name of candace
bergin she is a conservative member of
the house of commons and man she tore
trudeau a new one
mr speaker and i apologize that that
minister is misleading canadians i do
get very defensive of canadians who are
outside today patriotic peace-loving
canadians who are called misogynists and
racist by the prime minister
so again i will ask the prime minister
who may i remind this house war black
face on more times than he can remember
apologize to the peace loving patriotic
canadians who are outside right now just
asking to be heard will he speak to them
here we've got video of scott mo he is
the premier of saskatchewan that's in
western canada i love that name
saskatchewan uh announcing a plan to
fully return back to normal life why
would he be doing that do you think it
may be is because the people are finally
standing up
so now
and our caucus mlas are hearing this
from the people that they are talking to
across the province and the people that
they ultimately represent
and people are asking their government
for a return to normal
a removal of public health restrictions
and we most certainly
are looking at how we can do that in the
weeks ahead here in saskatchewan and now
it i think it is in fairness it is time
for us as a government to do what
saskatchewan people are asking for what
does that tell you what does that tell
you it tells you that we have the power
in the first place and it and the lesson
of this thing is that we've all got to
stick a pin in it we've got to say no
more we have to remember this moment
so that when they come again and they'll
come for climate lockdowns and they'll
come for all kinds of [ __ ] that we can't
even imagine this was the test run for
much worse stuff i think that's pretty
obvious but we must remember that
politicians can be moved they can be
moved but they can be moved by us we the
people so a truck convoy driving across
canada well suddenly you've got
politicians going oh i guess the people
are a little upset and maybe we should
do something about it